et maintenant nous allons retrouver
notre Père Noël mais dans un tout autre
accoutrement voici Michel Yun dans le
rap du Père
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Noël le No le PER ils sont dans la place
ils sont pas venus pour pas tringer
représente cocotte Killer est
dites les Papa Noël je peux avoir une
photo dédicacée de Jean-Pierre rafarin
non non non non un implant de Mar
Olivier
Fogel alors un dis de Marl et
barn au moins une cassette du big
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deal les Pères Noël ils se déroul les
Pères Noël ils partent en cou les Pères
Noël le TA les Pères
[Musique]
Noël me opération forc obligé de
t'amuser fais gaffe on sait où est ta
cheminée pré
estcorou on
[Musique]
va
on Noël il se dérou Noël il en cou des
[Musique]
noëlël es en train de DMIR pendant tu
faisouiller
[Musique]
pastionëll se déroule les ver Noël il
part en coup les ver Noël fous le tawa
les ver Noël dans des kaïas saute saute
saute saute saute saute saute saute
saute saute saute saute en haut saute en
haut saute en bas saute en bas saute en
rond saute en rond saute en rond r r r
saute
[Musique]
sauteuteuteuteuteuteuteuteuteuteute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jaob
uteuteuteuteuteute les P Noël ils se
dérouille les P Noël ils partent en
trouille les P Noël tous ta pë
sont
Michel
avec Benjamin et killer